i want to play what's my sexy secret we
thought this might be kind of fun
we we found a guest named evelyn evelyn
is a lovely beautiful woman who has a
very specific sexy secret
ronnie's goal in this is to figure out
like a detective what the secret is by
asking yes or no questions and you know
when it comes to women ronnie is like a
pervy bloodhound
without further ado again
[Music]
thank you for having me
it's great to have you here evelyn you
have a secret
and it's a very good one i i happen to
know robin does not know it i don't know
ronnie is going to ask you
some yes and no questions and then we'll
see if ronnie can guess it let's see how
good he is all right ron you're right
he's the man for it so we'll see how he
goes
ron do you have any questions or are you
out of questions already
no i i um i have questions were you born
a woman
uh yes i was born a woman and that is
not my sexy secret okay i'm not i'm not
guessing yet i'm just asking questions
all right
how old are you ronnie wait a second
it's a yes or no question we you know we
had a bet going aside
we said how long before ronnie um
asks a non-yes or no question and he's
already done it
all right all right are you are you
transitioned no i'm not
you're not
does it have does it have something to
do does it have something to do
with your breasts
no it does not
does it have something to do with your
lower body
yes it does
hmm
ronnie dissecting
and probing surging
does this have something to do
with the ass area no it does not
uh the vagina area
yes
ronnie uh zeroing in
yeah he's he's getting i guess warmer
and you don't have a [__] right
no i don't have a
certain about that
do you have balls
i do not know
does it happen does this happen does it
have something to do with your clitoris
no not really
what what is that
no the answer is no question yeah yes
okay
are you wearing a butt plug right now
i wish i was wearing a butt plug like
that but no i'm not
[__]
let's get back to the real ronnie ronnie
uh let me remind you we have a seven
hour time limit on this one i say
ronnie's now poking around the vagina
but he still hasn't found the secret
yeah i'm poking around the vagina and it
seems like it's in that area whatever it
is
it has
something to do with the clitoris or it
doesn't
she said i remember the clitoris yeah no
yeah no she didn't really know
it would be a no it would be a no
it's a no she's absolutely it absolutely
is a no absolutely evelyn go ahead yeah
oh ask her man you know it's it's not
that easy to you know to decipher this
[__] here i thought you were the
expert on sex listen i'm getting i'm get
i'm in the general area i'm just trying
all right figure it out i'm sorry what
the hell is going on you know go ahead
go ahead go ahead another another
question then i mean i watched my line
at least they gave some kind of [__]
clue
i have no clue it is and she has a sexy
secret yeah i get that wait i got i got
a question
can you toss your [__] like a boomerang
all right
now let ronnie ask the question
is is your [__] functional yes
does it have something to do with the
lips of
the vagina
no no no
i i vote we don't end the show until
ronnie figures it out
we'll be here till next week i'm willing
let's see if you were right
you say you'll sit here all week
evelyn i have a yes or no question are
you willing to sit here all week until
ronnie gets the uh are you [__]
kidding me dude
i asked like 10 questions so far and
already you're busting my balls about
come on go ahead i told you i'm in the
[__] general area i'm just trying to
decipher what is going on um
do you have
what they claim to be a special g-spot
no
you don't ronnie you're doing well
you're in the area i can see the rusty
gears in your head turning
it's tough man to try and guess what the
hell she could have
but
ask questions ronnie i'm asking
questions robin
he's trying to think but nothing's
happening
asking questions well the ronnie puppet
is itching to ask a question i don't do
it right i do i do i do does your [__]
juice taste like vegemite
no i hope not
damn
you thought you were on to something
puppet what are you wearing by the way
is that a overalls you're wearing
a
dress a dress i'm pregnant i've got to
wear dresses at the minute
oh you're pregnant okay that's
interesting
she's pregnant
yeah so i was born again because i am
pregnant
but you have a [__] too
no i don't
[Laughter]
is your vagina inverted i'm not sure
what that means but
isn't a vagina inverted by nature
a nanny not yeah
outing
yes wait can you tie your [__] lips and
a knot
i haven't tried that before i'm not sure
can we give him questions because this
is getting tedious
uh you want to help them robin
no
robin's question is do you have a car
robin
i hope she has a [__]
big shot robin
come on robin join in and have a
question
does her vagina do something special
as the moderator evelyn i would say yes
your vagina does do something right okay
see ronnie now go
yeah robin just helped
by the way evelyn ronnie is the perry
mason of muff and he's stumped so this
is pretty good your secrets are good
by the way he's the one to fake
well evelyn i have a question um were
you born a man
no that's that's a that's a question
i
asked it seven times three times
all right ronnie puppet has a question
go ahead ronnie puppet does your vagina
play the clarinet
yes
that's it you got it no it's not that
that is not the secret it's got to be
something [__] weird and i can't you
can't put my finger on it it's i'm kind
of i'm starting are you i'm throwing in
the towel
i'm stumped i i mean like how many
questions could i keep asking
and i'm getting no answers you know you
get you're getting it she's saying yes
or no to each of your questions yeah i
get it i get it you know what's great
about you
you know what's great about you that
first of all this is how i predict you
must have been like in school you ask
seven questions and you give up you know
what i mean like giving up i'm just
trying to dig in
get tired you're [__] yelling at me
and she's yelling at me and i'm trying
to figure it out all right maybe the
puppet will help you you ask a question
uh ronnie puppet do you have a man's
vagina shut the [__] up
smoke's coming out of your ears now let
me ask one more question go ahead robin
go ahead maybe this will help your
vagina
anatomically
like every other woman no
all right go
come on ronnie that's robin just put you
right on the right path want to take a
guess before i reveal and flip all the
cards
uh i'm stomped
i got really strong can i can i guess
you can in a minute after let the puppet
ask one more question go ahead one more
one more question can you walk on your
vagina lips like a snail
i don't think so
uh
robin what i'm gonna do
all right go ahead robin
do you have more than one vagina
yes
there you go
there's the answer robin got it
you got it evelyn
has vaginas
how how does that happen
how does that happen
all right in all my years of watching
all kinds of crazy [__] porn and
whatever i've never seen that before
yeah evelyn let's explain exactly what's
going on here we're flipping all the
cards robin congratulations you weren't
even playing well
i was like i knew like three questions
in but you know
[Laughter]
robin asked two questions you asked 57
right yeah and 50 of them were the same
question fine here we go i lost okay
i admit it i lost
let me explain to you what's going on
here evelyn was born with uterus
d-delphis it is a condition that can
cause people to be born with double
reproductive organs evelyn knew at 14
there was something different about her
vagina because tampons didn't work
evelyn's condition was diagnosed at 20
when she went to terminate a pregnancy
and she found out she had two not one
two
vaginas this condition is estimated to
affect one in every 3 000 women it often
goes undetected unless there are
complications of getting her staying
pregnant and she can technically get
pregnant in both vaginas
wow that would have been my next
question
yeah okay doc
is there two separate holes
yes yes holy [__]
that's it
holy [__] that's different but yes it is
ronnie
yes ronnie is your mind blown ronnie
right that's mine
i'm very lucky hey ma one's out for an
oil change today and the other ones
still work and said come on in
ronnie picture a um a cave
and in the cave is a right entrance and
a left entrance so there you go there's
two vaginas yeah yeah wait can you have
a two different periods because you have
two two different uteruses yeah i have
two periods like one out of each side so
i have to use the tampon in each side
but i get the periods at the same time
every month oh you do
yeah yeah wow
you know
i'm just trying to picture this is it
like they're one on top of the other or
something like that
like yeah there's like a and then
there's like a big wall in the middle of
them like eyeballs
holy [__] man that's crazy
yeah and when you use your vaginas does
one work better than the other sexually
does one give you let's say a greater
orgasm or um
or some more intense experience i sort
of have to judge the guy and then choose
a side as to which i think will look
better
when did she actually discover this you
say you were terminating a pregnancy or
something yeah i didn't actually find
out until i went to have a termination
and um they told me the embryo wasn't in
there and it wasn't until they had just
another look and they saw the other hole
and uh realized it was still in my other
uterus so ah
so you have complete you have cute
kids she masturbated both of them at the
same time yeah do that little time
ronnie you're left
running
dude i'm not laughing i'm not laughing i
i just think it's [__] amazing
i'm not laughing i'm just like
dumbfounded
wait you were saying evelyn you could
have sex in one and what was the rest of
the sentence i know you said you would
do on the other side
oh wow
why
you could be having sex on one side and
a dildo on the other side
yeah fun ronnie is acting like a caveman
who just discovered fire
he is downright giddy i got to check
this out
do you use both of them with your
partner yeah
which one does he like better
well he likes he's his
dick is bent a little bit to the left
he's left yeah so it goes goes in the
right side normally but it feels better
in like certain positions in the left
like doggy and stuff i just want to know
if she has names for them so when he's
choosing
but i wish i wish
you should name them
actually okay that's a great idea
ronnie's hero now you're gonna get a
special little award in the ronnie
museum
oh yeah well this is some story
this is some story ronnie are you okay
yeah yeah
you don't look good
i'm telling you he's been changed by
this it really has changed him it really
affected him and uh let me tell you has
she ever come has she ever come together
with both of them at the same time
yeah well that's why it's very intense
when i use two dildos or like a second
ones you'll do that's why i like it i
think my partner gets a bit offended
when i get the spare tilt out
but that must be some explosion
by the way i do want to mention on
tomorrow's show we have a man with nine
penises coming in
it looks like otters but uh they're the
real ready get your questions ready
ronnie you gotta get it oh you're ready
yep well let me tell you something i'm
calling this a home run and we celebrate
you evelyn it's [__] awesome as
ronnie says uh everyone loves a woman
with two vaginas ronnie already has a
fantasy he's gonna be oh my goodness his
head has gone through about a billion
fantasies
yeah he likes it he likes it and ronnie
puppet you have fantasies too i know
that i do i also have some advice for
her if she's ever walking through a bad
neighborhood she should use one of her
[__] to hide her money in ah right
that's right
that way
that way your money is safe
and he's both [__]
right
yes yes
she's got two [__]
ronnie's dream come true
all right very nice she's gonna love two
she's got two that's right all right
well thank you evelyn
you